I don't really like speaking about it to  my friend and how I was living in that  way and stuff sometimes is quite  embarrassing my mom was quite stressed  out and upset because she was pregnant  with Malik lion going for a lot it's  quite stressful because you like have to  unpack and impact and then settle in  again and then move again it is quite  annoying because when you have your end  of year six and tests and you can't  really em do revised because sometimes  you have to let help my hat tell my mum  and then wait for them to get out of the  bathroom upstairs and then have a bath  and go toilet and then get changed and  go to bed so you didn't really have that  much time to do anything you can't like  just that you'll be somewhere for a  while and then you'll be somewhere else  for a while and you can't like relax and  stay slight your home